enfin enfin je ne comprends pas il doit
prendre le bateau qui part dans une
heure il ne connaît rien des pays qu'il
va visiter julie tu m'écoutes tu parles
est une excuse moi mais je suis très
occupé il faut que je termine le
sandwich de casimir et je n'aurais
jamais fini il prend le bateau dans une
heure il ne faut quand même pas une
heure pour préparer un sandwich en
écoute ce qui m'a écrit tu comprends pas
hr julie je voudrais que tu me prépares
à sandwich pour mon voyage
surtout ne fait rien de compliqué et
bien devoir il ne te demande qu'un
sandwich tout simplement laisse-moi
continuer s'il te plaît donc je suis
plus aujourd'hui la photo merci mais il
seulement du jambon de la moutarde du
beurre des fraises une tomate de la
mayonnaise du solution de la crème
chantilly beaucoup dans son esprit
depuis suisse à la groseille du lard
fumé des épinards de la confiture
d'ananas que je fais mais je ne fais que
commencer
le guardian a sur toute la longueur du
rouleau c'est incroyable julie julie
casimir te voilà en fait bien dit mon
dieu oh mais ce n'est pas à toi que je
parle c'est à julie de nommer mais julie
est très occupée par barton sandwich à
mais justement julie j'espère que tu ne
l'as pas terminée non j'en suis à peine
à la moitié à bon ça va parce qu il
faudrait rajouter des cadres mais il
faut les mettre
juste avant la crème de marron c'est
tout enfin je crois oui je sais je veux
quelque chose de très simple
nancy rendu compte casimir si tu ne veux
pas te perdre en route il faut que tu
viennes étudier un petit peu les pays
que tu va traverser ce n'est pas la
haine je connais tous c'est très facile
oui bien à plombs quand même les enfants
ils vont nous aider au cou ce n'est
vraiment pas la peine je n'ai pas besoin
d'eux on verra bien on verra bien les
enfants venaient nous allons faire un
jeu absolument que nous étions casimir
venez vous voulez mais c'est inutile je
connais tous casimir part en voyage il a
décidé de visiter tous les pays qui ont
une frontière commune avec la france
lire plus tous les pays qui la touche
vous les connaissez
oui et vos essais oui et non oui on va
voir
commençons par le nord comment s'appelle
midi quand la belgique l'a très bien
ah oui oui là quel est le nom de la
capitale de la belgique
très bien bruxelles capitale de la
belgique à la belgique oui oui ensuite
ce petit pays
le grand duché du luxembourg vient très
bien lui donner le nom de la capitale
grand duché du luxembourg
laurence non c'est tout simple c'est
justement luxembourg bah oui là
évidemment rouge le cache complètement
là tout petit pays qu'une grandes
étiquettes les sont quasi n'y répondent
maintenant casimir
quel est le nom de ce pays celui là
c'est facile ça alors c'est là la voix
c'est celle au mexique
quel est le nom de sa capitale
new york c'est une bonne réponse alors
quel est le nom de ce pays les enfants
ah non non c'est l'allemagne la jugeait
les noms de sa capitale bonne alors jeu
mais bon bon bah cbl ah voilà
l'allemagne capital bonne voie la d112
le nous de ce pays très bonne réponse à
vous connaissez le nom la capitale de la
suisse non c'est bien
ah bah oui mais lausanne vers les
étiquettes sont suisses à casimir
maintenant casimir braille quel est le
nom de ce pays a une frontière avec la
france sas est une c'est une chaussette
non c'était chaud cette annonce est un
pays c'est ça s'appelle un ça s'appelle
ça s'appelle jeunesse a soufflé lui à
l'italie oui c'est ça à licques alger a
pas trouvé seul nom et ça n'a pas la foi
d'une chaussette mais la forme d'une
botte pour finir et du connaît le nom de
la capitale de l'italie
et bien c'est c'est ça c'est ça je suis
bail
ils ont tous aimé alors l'italie c est
ce pays je ne savais rien et le nom la
capitale la capitale madrid
ah bah oui oui madrid oui images leader
en espagne
casimir tout sandwich est prêt et bien
voilà casimir tu as appris beaucoup de
choses maintenant tu vas partir droit tu
nous avais ras des cartes postales
je crois que je vais être obligé de
retarder un peu mon départ pourquoi
casimir maintenant tu connais tous les
nous les pays que dure la visiter et tu
as le sandwich que tu souhaitais mais
non justement ce n'est pas un sandwich
de voyage ça lorsque j'aurais mangé ce
sens drx là il me faudra au moins une
journée pour le digérer
alors
hu
[Musique]